President Bush tried to have no permit
political enemies even after he lost his
reelection campaign he became friends
with the Democrat who defeated him
former President Bill Clinton wrote in
The Washington Post this weekend I
cherished every opportunity I had to
learn and laugh with him I just loved
him he was in it for the right reasons
people always came before politics
patriotism before partisanship chief
White House correspondent major Garrett
covered Congress during President Bush's
term major good morning good morning
let's start with that 1990 budget deal
the breaking of the no new taxes pledge
why is that such an important point
because it began a division within
Republican Party that created a harder
approach to taxation led by Newt
Gingrich he did not support the
president though the president assumed
he would in his minority position in the
House Republicans Bush loses in 92
because of the split in the party
Gingrich becomes the revolutionary
leader in 1994 the first Republican
majority in Congress in 40 years and
then you have the Tea Party and then you
have a bit of Donald Trump I mean all
this is part of a pattern the split in
the Republican Party first really fought
over that budget deal is still with us
today and there's a stylistic difference
too because President Bush thought with
this deal he was making a bipartisan
arrangement of the road style and what
did Newt Gingrich represent he said to
Republicans we have lived with a
minority mentality for forty years we
always cut deals with Democrats this
deal epitomized what he thought was
George HW Bush's central weakness he
always cut deals with Democrats and
Republicans led by Gingrich said those
days have got to end we have to
establish what we're for and let
Democrats deal with it we've spent a lot
of time talking about his presidency in
terms of Foreign Affairs of course
reordering a global order but
domestically it was so fascinating what
was going on as you point out because
you were there a democratic-controlled
Congress the legislation he passed
significant and signed along with that
Congress the Americans with Disabilities
Act yes the Clean Air Act yes oh the
authorization of the Civil Rights Act
one thing I'd like to make clear
bipartisanship is not easy we kid
ourselves where this Ghazi sends the
bipartisanship just naturally happens it
doesn't first you have to prioritize it
then you have to work it Clean Air Act
classic example who was leading that
committee John Dingell he had populated
that committee with people who were
opposed to the Clean Air Act other
Democrats the Bush White House worked
around them
with hot with Henry Waxman the
California Democrat we have clean air
and cleaner water now because of this
bipartisan achievement but it was by no
means easy and it takes a certain amount
of political bravery to achieve it we
all remember the wimp factor for George
HW Bush when it came to domestic
politics and legislation it was anything
but it went that's right the wind factor
that Newsweek cover story questioning
whether he was tough enough for the job
major thank you
we need more of your brilliance major I
always love hearing for you